propos du premier ministre mais c'est
dans un fait l'actualité assez
rapidement on va venir quand même au
sujet de préoccupation qui est le vôtre
actuellement essentiellement de
l'informatique et de l'ergonomie relents
va utiliser des mots que je crois neuf
français sur dix ne comprennent pas
qu'est ce que c'est que l'ergonomie
l'ergonomie c'est la prise en compte de
l'effort de l'homme de sa fatigue ou de
ces risques d'erreur lorsqu'on le place
devant une machine et qu'on met au
travail
alors il y a des médecins qui regarde
comment l'acuité visuelle ou la fatigue
auditive le bruit etc
avant de donner de la fatigue et finale
devant nuire à la bonne exécution et
font dire à la personne qui exécute
mais est il y a aussi une ergonomie
intellectuelle et c'est celle que nous
avons essayé de traiter à lyria et qui
est particulièrement importante lorsque
s'est produit informatique seront mis
dans tous les bureaux et que la plupart
des secrétaires la plupart des
archivistes des bibliothécaires vu aussi
les médecins les avocats qui s'avère
avant servir de nos terminaux
je crois que c'est de voir cela peut
être une image hors jeu clergé jean
patrick esther a pu visiter à nouveau
laboratoire aline veillât et il a
enregistré là-bas une série de relations
entre l'homme et la machine dont
quelques-unes vous verrez montre bien
qu'on peut améliorer ces relations et
des au travail voilà donc je suis j'ai
tourné par patrick esther dans un des
laboratoires de l'inria
bien peu de gens accepteront de
travailler huit heures par jour avec ce
type de machine avec ce type d'écran
particulière fatigant pour la vue etc
pour améliorer les relations entre la
machine et l'homme qu'ici à l'inria un
certain nombre de chercheurs étudient
des solutions particulières nouvelle
l'amélioration la plus notable
concernera le remplacement des écrans de
vie de télévision actuelle par des
écrans à plasma qui seront moins
fatiguant pour les yeux des utilisateurs
le deuxième la deuxième améliorations
que l'on peut attendre et le
remplacement de l'actuel clavier qui est
le plus répandu par des systèmes de
désignation par le doigt le sujet n'aura
qu'à désigner directement sur l'écran
avec son doigt le mot ou la zone qu'il
veut repérée et l'ordinateur lui
répondra le deuxième dispositif qui
permettra une amélioration très sensible
et le traitement automatique de la
parole le l'opérateur parlera comme on
parle à une autre personne et
l'ordinateur interprétera directement la
voix de lummen
autre axe de recherche la simplification
du langage de la machine pour le rendre
accessible à tous
avec ce système impressionnant on étudie
ici la manière dont une opératrice des
chiffres un écran on enregistre tous les
mouvements des yeux grâce à une
minuscule caméra placée sur la tête
on peut ensuite en déduire les zones de
l'écran qui sont délaissés au contraire
souvent parcourue par le regard
on pourra ainsi présenter les mots
importants aux endroits les plus
évidents mais allons plus loin
le tableau de chiffres que compulser
cette jeune femme n'est guère lisieux et
bien l'ordinateur va transformer ce
tableau austère en une image facile à
interpréter d'un seul coup d'oeil ce
programme mise au point à l'inria peut
servir à représenter l'évolution du prix
les carottes aussi bien qu'une équation
mathématique ou que la topographie d'un
terrain décidément l'ordinateur offre
des possibilités aussi vaste que variés
il peut même maintenant décider des
génériques de télévision